hi i'm maitrey rob christian my name is
darren barnett ramona young
megan suri lee rodriguez i'm jaren
lewison we're the cast of never have i
ever and today
we are doing the wired autocomplete
interview
[Music]
my stomach just dropped i don't know why
i know
it's scary
[Music]
i've always wanted to do this
who does jaron lewison look like
i don't know i feel like this is a cast
question guys who don't who do i look
like
you kind of almost look like a little
bit of john krasinski
kind of i will superintendent
yeah that's a compliment i will for sure
when i was younger i used to get um
elijah woods that's where you see it
when i was younger
krasinski and elijah would had a kid
okay
jaren lewison barney and friends
yes of course if you're a really good
internet
sleuth you can find my barney episodes
which was the first thing i ever did
as an actor when i was like seven or
eight years old you can find them on
youtube i know my tray has seen them
because i exposed myself pretty sure
we've all seen them oh you everybody's
okay
it brings me joy i had very large hair
uh i have no teeth you'll yeah it's uh
it's
[Music]
yeah i've got tag i've got men women and
children i've got a couple i want to
keep doing more you were in
tag yeah i played a teen version of ed
helms's character hoagy
yeah i didn't get to meet him but i saw
him
like while i was doing a fitting but i
was too nervous to go say anything
where does my trait rama krishnan
go to school shout out meadowvale
meadowville gang
but technically i am enrolled in
university i gotta always say it do you
guys know
you say that every time every time i
have to shout out the meadowvale homies
the only reason i'm here is because of
good old public education okay so let me
have that
does my rama krishnan
play harp okay so i didn't play harp
prior
to davey but i did take a lot of hard
lessons so
during monday to friday every day that
would be filming
and then on my saturday it would be hard
lesson day
and that would be like two hours at the
heart trying to like you know make sure
it looked super authentic when i was
playing and then also like
out of my own curiosity so if you give
me a heart i'm not the one playing the
song though let's get that clear i'm not
like that
i will play you like some simple nice
stuff but
i've heard you play a little bit for
real and you you're better than you're
making it out to be she's she's
very musical everyone you're like a
master at
piano and she can sing okay okay
okay okay thank you thank you thank you
violin's there too
does my ramakrishnan
oh oh this one's a tricky one
speaking tamil
i'm assuming it's asking if i do speak
thermal i don't speak them
fluently i actually only really
understand it because everyone in my
household
does speak thermal and i've always been
surrounded by thummel
i personally do not speak thumble but i
could say you know vanakkam
you know the typical kind of stuff but
yeah i like to know the survival words
like water
tanni idiot aka
food because that's what matters
this is movie what movie does darren
barnett play in
i did a lifetime movie forever ago
called insta killer
i'm currently working on a movie called
apophenia it's a psychothriller
very excited about that that will be
within the next
two years probably that that will be
coming out my question is are you the
psycho in it
and are you like i am a complete nutcase
in it
wow
what is darren barnett's snapchat
[Music]
they want to add you darren i don't ever
use it
or check it um but i think it's
truth or darin i thought that was oh
okay
that's actually great it's so
bad it's good what episode of criminal
minds was dan barnett in
it's episode 20 of like no it's season
13 episode 20 i think it's called
unforgettable
it's kind of ironic you you you realize
that
yeah we can figure so one of those 2013
or 13
20. so something like that the episode's
titled unforgettable
paxson never have i ever
shirt scene yeah hello
so originally uh our director wanted me
to take
my shirt off from behind with one hand
and rip it off but i
kept literally like choking myself
trying to do it so i decided to do it
this way where i
spin it off with the arm they had me in
like a size small
to figure flatter myself i needed them
to give me a bigger size shirt to rip it
off easier
um but i got that second take
i believe and also a lot of people ask
if it was sped up
was not sped up i will vouch
it was second take who does paxton blank
and never have i ever date that you are
going to have to
find out in season 2 of never have i
ever
what blank is paxton and never have i
grade paxson is a junior
at sherman oaks high never have i ever
does
demi davie end up with paxton so it's
not demi lovato
i don't think so i don't think she's in
our show unless there's a spoiler
for that you're going to have to watch
season two
never have i ever you'll find out soon
gotta see it when did megan surry
start acting professionally since i was
eight years old
oh my first role was actually a honda
commercial with my
dad never aired but nevertheless
free food first experience with crafting
great okay great man i was with it
that's wholesome
that's so wholesome with your dad too
super wholesome super wholesome
who is anissa never have i ever
anisa is a 16 year old transfer student
from a private school who goes to
sherman oaks
and i play her megan sorry
13 reasons why
so okay let's get into it my scene got
cut
and i'm over it okay i'm over it i'm
totally over it
not at all matt no genuinely i'm
actually not it was such a cool
experience they
sent like a car to my house to pick me
up to take me to the airport
and there was like a guy in a suit
holding his phone
like this with my name on it when i got
it was crazy i felt like
i that was like the first time in a long
time where i was like i'm
an actor what it was crazy so great
experience didn't air
who did megan surry play in valentine's
day
i played a character named rainey um
and that was it was life-changing i got
to work with
so many actors that i grew up watching
it was super surreal couldn't have been
luckier for like my first job
insane i think i was nine years old
perhaps yeah
nine years old i think it came out in
2010 so i was i was uh
yeah nine years old yeah is that the
movie taylor swift is in
yeah dude yeah don't watch it though
please i'm trying to
so proof it i'm gonna go live you know
that right yeah
i want ramona to rip off her own
questions
wow rude okay
i'm scared ramona young
13 reasons why my scene
was cut no i'm just kidding
i uh have never seen 13 reasons
don't know i've auditioned i think for
one of the seasons
and uh you know probably like every
other
young adult actor in l.a when ramona
young
singer back in 1984
i worked at a jazz club as a singer
when ramona young singer what does that
mean
it means you're saying well yeah when
did you start singing ramona
never professionally so i sing for fun
maybe they're telling the future and
that you're gonna be a singer
maybe maybe maybe i should start a band
but let the record show ramona's a very
very talented singer like
very talented great voice thanks man
[Music]
thank you
instagram follow me ramona bish
young ramona fish yo
ramona fish that's how you say it i like
it
how tall is lee rodriguez
i recently found out that i am not five
nine
i am five eight and a half and i've been
saying
that i'm five nine this whole time it's
a shock
i think i'm just gonna keep saying i'm
five nine so the answer is
five nine and you've been telling people
on set that you were 510 and that you've
been growing
exactly i thought i really thought i was
where
is lee rodriguez right now
i am in my publicist's office
fair enough a nice wall behind you is
lee rodriguez
married no i am not married
all right straight forward let's make it
what has leigh rodriguez been in i've
been in
grownish and i don't know this
this snap chat show called class of lies
and never have i ever how old is lee
rodriguez
i am 21. what
oh i believe that says grade what grade
is davey in never have i ever uh she's
in grade 10
sorry sophomore she's a sophomore
in 10th grade i say grade 10.
it just makes sense hey that makes sense
to me
what
spend oh cute
what happened to davey what happened to
davey
and never have i ever that's a general
question there's a lot there's a lot
that happens
um her dad dies first 15 minutes
straight out the gate real sad heart
attack
not fun she finds love she's got great
best friends
her cousin moves in sort of weird but
maybe they get along
her mom can be a lot a lot happens to
davey
what episode of never have i ever do
and ben yes
oh that was a bit of a sneak i'm so
sorry for those
who haven't watched the show at all if
you haven't
interesting choice that you're watching
this video of all of us here but for
those of you guys who have
yeah last episode uh malibu like
probably the last
five minutes there yeah steamy
great scene i have a question to follow
up with that that just comes out of my
own curiosity
how many takes did you guys do for that
a lot
yeah wow i think that's just like
because it's all different angles and
different setups and then there was like
that drone shot where it like
peels out over the look of malibu so we
were kissing during that too because it
starts out on us
and so a lot is the answer and then it's
not even
just in malibu then you have to like
film it on the stage with like screens
for the actual scene so
you're welcome fans that's a good
question megan
that was nerve-wracking awesome
and i i think i need to go pass out damn
okay
i thought it was pretty fun yeah i
enjoyed that
thank you for watching the wired auto
complete interview
remember to check out never have i ever
on netflix july 15th